Public Sénat et écho DDS vous présente
pourvu que ça dure
[Musique]
bonjour nouveau numéro de pourvu que ça
dure l'émission qui rend l'écho
responsable sur Public Sénat smartphone
ordinateur télévision la vaisselle ou
encore lave-linge aujourd'hui on vous
parle de l'indice de réparabilité qui
accompagne nos appareils du quotidien 2
ans après son lancement quel bilan et
distributeurs affiche-t-il bien cet
indice les marques ont-elles plus
d'efforts dans leur processus de
fabrication le consommateur est-il plus
enclin aujourd'hui à réparer qu'à
acheter et bien réponse avec le
président de l'association alt à
l'obsolescence programmée pour relever
ce défi de la réparation disposons
d'Asset de main d'oeuvre et d'accès aux
pièces détachées reportage à suivre dans
cette émission enfin focus sur l'un des
plus gros acteurs de l'électrique et de
l'électronique qui n'a pas attendu cet
indice pour se lancer Enrique et
Martinez le patron de Fnac Darty sera
avec nous dans cette émission mais
d'abord tout ce qu'il faut savoir sur
certains disent de réparabilité en moins
d'une minute c'est parti l'indice de
réparabilité c'est quoi au juste prévu
dans la loi anti-gaspillage il concerne
cinq familles un produit les smartphones
les ordinateurs portables les télés les
lave-linge à hublots et les tondeuses à
gazon et depuis novembre 2022 les
lave-vaisselles les aspirateurs les
lave-linge qui se chargent sur le dessus
et enfin les nettoyeurs haute pression
et comment il fonctionne comme à l'école
nos appareils sont notés de 1 à 10 avec
pour nous aider des codes couleurs du
vert foncé pour les bons élèves au rouge
vif pour les cancres cette note elle est
établie en fonction de 5 critères dont
l'accès à la documentation technique le
caractère démontable du produit la
disponibilité ou le prix des pièces
détachées et cette note on la trouve
partout les fabricants doivent en
principe fournir cette note au
distributeur qui eux ont l'obligation de
l'afficher en magasin et sur Internet à
côté du prix s'ils ne le font pas il
s'exposent depuis le 1er janvier 2022 à
des sanctions financières mais dans les
faits 52% des établissements ne
respectent pas la loi il est français
eux ils sont prêts à réparer plutôt qu'à
racheter pour l'instant
seul 36% répare leurs appareils quand
ils tombent en panne avec l'indice de
réparabilité le gouvernement espère
atteindre un taux de réparation de 60%
en 2026 pour aider les ménages un bonus
de réparation a été instauré le 15
décembre dernier
[Musique]
quel bilan pour l'indice de réparabilité
2 ans après sa création et ce qu'il a
fait évoluer les comportements des
consommateurs mais aussi des fabricants
bonjour quentingeker bonjour merci
d'être là avec nous vous êtes le
président de l'association hop alt à
l'obsolescence programmée c'est indice
vous connaissez bien puisque vous avez
œuvré sa création aux côtés de l'État et
de tous les acteurs d'ailleurs concernés
il faut le dire quel bilan on peut en
tirer déjà côté distributeur est-ce que
tout le monde joue le jeu ou pas
vraiment bah justement c'est une très
bonne question on a rendu un rapport en
octobre dernier pour montrer enfin pour
justement savoir si les fabricants
jouaient ou pas le jeu et cette enquête
compléter une enquête de la DGCCRF qui
avait qui a eu été rendu le 27 septembre
dernier et qui montre que non
50% des distributeurs affichaient pas
l'indice de réparabilité à date donc en
septembre nous on a montré en octobre
qu'on était même encore plus haut sur
les sur les distributeurs qu'on avait
contrôlé on était autour de 60 % sur les
catégories de produits qui étaient à
leur en vigueur du coup c'était
smartphone ordinateur
lave-linge hublot et j'en oublie
toujours un
c'est lequel en tout cas les étiquettes
voilà ne sont pas suffisamment loin de
là afficher dans les rayons pourtant les
vendeurs ont l'obligation les
distributeurs de retirer les produits
depuis janvier 2021 et depuis un an
janvier 2022 il s'expose même à des
sanctions de la part de la répression
des fraudes et dans les faits il y a
évidemment bah alors pour l'instant nous
on n'a pas connaissance d'amende qui ont
été infligées pourtant bah oui elle
s'expose à des amendes 3000 euros pour
une personne physique 15.000 euros si
c'est une personne morale d'ailleurs on
a ça reste très théorique je veux dire
pour l'instant oui c'était vrai mais
justement nous ce qu'on veut ce qu'on
qu'on peut faire c'est que c'est
d'appeler à la responsabilité de cette
distributeurs c'est pour ça qu'on a fait
une action coup de poing en novembre
dernier à l'entrée en vigueur sur les
nouvelles sur les nouvelles catégories
de produits pour dire que c'est pas
possible ça suffit pas qu'il faut aller
plus loin et si cette responsabilité
collective des distributeurs des
vendeurs en fait sur qui pèse
l'obligation qu'on veut sur lesquels on
va alerter en tout cas il faudrait que
la répression des fraudes façon boulot
aussi qu'elle fasse appliquer la loi
effectivement c'est notre appel c'est
qu'on veut que la DGCCRF renforce ses
contrôles pour créer un effet de
mouvement en fait que derrière les
vendeurs se disent ah bah oui on peut
pas être impuni pour ça c'est une vraie
obligation qui pèse sur nous même si
c'est nouveau même si on a des excuses
bah en fait c'est la loi il faut la
respecter ça c'est ce qu'on veut après
distributeur et fabricants se renvoient
un petit peu la balle sur les
responsabilités effectivement il y a pas
d'enquête pour le moment qui montre que
la faute incombe particulièrement
fabriquant ou particulièrement
en fait l'enquête de la DGCCRF qui a été
menée et notre enquête à nous a montré
que ça pouvait être à la fois affiché
sur le site des fabricants mais pas chez
les distributeurs des fois chez les
distributeurs mais pas chez les
fabricants donc en fait il y a un
gloubi-boulgal là dedans et on veut
faire en sorte de d'éclaircir la
situation en appelant en fait la
responsabilité collective peu importe
que la que ce soit la faute du fabricant
à ce stade ou du vendeur quel rôle aussi
là pour le couple pour les pouvoirs
publics les tailles évidemment un rôle à
jouer lors du Forum de la durabilité en
novembre dernier vers Couillard la
secrétaire d'État chargée de l'écologie
a annoncé justement à qu'une enquête
nationale allait être menée merci de
m'avoir un peu sifflet siffler le mot
c'est exactement ce qui s'est ce qui
s'est passé alors maintenant à ce stade
on n'a pas à de plus d'éléments sur ce
que va comporter cette enquête nationale
en tout cas nous on veillera à ce que
cette enquête soit une réelle avancée
une réelle poussée et pour savoir si à
la fin c'est du Larousse du cochon ça va
voir si c'était un effet d'annonce et
qu'à la fin c'est juste un coup de fil à
la dire à la déchetterie CRF aussi y
avoir des ressources supplémentaires
pour le contrôle le lundi on a parlé des
distributeurs il faut parler des
fabricants et ce qu'il note est-ce qu'il
note correctement leurs produits parce
que on en vient au choix des critères
évidemment pour établir ces notes il y a
cinq critères tout se valent or certains
critères et je vous laisse parler sont
plus importants que d'autres ce qu'on a
montré c'est qu'en général les
fabricants se surnotes de 1,3 moyenne
dans sur les values c'est là où c'est
comme une bizarine ouais complètement il
s'auto-évalue alors ça ce que c'est le
même on se dit qu'on ça devient vite et
que des fois elles ont une grille de
critères à respecter quand même donc
elles sont quand même reste enfin elles
sont cinq critères c'est ça elles sont
contraintes sous cette grille qu'elles
doivent publier mais c'est une synthèse
en fait et donc du coup il y a des
marges d'interprétation qui permettent
pas de dire si oui ou non à la fin on
était sur une une note voilà qui était
on était à 7 en fait on est à 8 sauf que
dans le comportement du consommateur
c'est c'est très c'est très différent
d'avoir cette nous ce qu'on dit c'est
que l'indice il est perfectible
aujourd'hui il est il est perfectible
dans à bien des égards notamment sur la
pondération c'est pas normal que toutes
les notes par effet de compensation
puisse être plus se relever les unes les
autres je prends un exemple la
démontabilité des produits qui est
important c'est le plus important à quoi
ça sert d'avoir des pièces détachées à
un prix abordable si on peut pas vous
pouvez même pas ouvrir votre appareil
sans le casser du coup et en fait
pourquoi on attribuerait du coup une
bonne note un appareil qui est même pas
démontable ce qui est possible
aujourd'hui d'être réalisé avec l'indice
de réparabilité donc nous ce qu'on a ce
qu'on veut ce qu'on veut faire c'est de
faire relever s'il y a plusieurs options
possibles mais on veut un système de
pondération un meilleur système par
exemple
la démontabilité serait une condition
sinequanone côté consommateur maintenant
cette réparabilité est-ce que c'est
devenu je me disais un vrai critère
d'achat pris en compte au début au même
titre que le prix ou que la performance
du produit alors il faut qu'on mette à
jour nos données mais effectivement au
1er mars 2022
c'est indice était connu d'environ 50%
des consommateurs qu'on avait interrogés
et dans trois quarts des cas pour eux
c'était un indice qui était extrêmement
utile du coup on montre que oui oui il a
une utilité et c'est en d'autant plus
important aujourd'hui que c'est à
l'achat et c'est d'autant plus important
aujourd'hui que le consommateur avant
avait aucun indice sur la réparabilité
il pouvait pas savoir si l'appareil
qu'il a acheté était réparable ou pas à
moins de se farfouiller dans des détails
techniques qui n'étaient pas accessibles
au grand public et c'est ce que permet
aujourd'hui c'est indice il y a l'acte
d'achat puis après il y a le moment où
l'article produit tombera pas est-ce que
les gens aujourd'hui réparent plus ou
est-ce qu'ils vont toujours se rabattre
malheureusement sur un sur un produit
neuf il y a une prise de conscience et
me dire oui mais après ce qu'il y a
est-ce qu'on est à l'étape d'après au
passage à l'acte justement là il y a
encore beaucoup de travail à faire
on est au début là effectivement lundi
de réparabilité il monte si ce sera
réparable ou pas il y a pas encore
d'études qui peuvent montrer il faut
encore un peu de temps avant de montrer
si lundi de réparabilité a eu un effet
sur l'ensemble des produits concernés
sur la réparation il parce qu'il y a
d'autres facteurs en fait qui rentrent
en ligne de compte pour savoir si on va
pouvoir réparer le prix le prix
psychologique enfin un frein
psychologique lié au prix ça coûte cher
mieux vaut acheter un neuf vous êtes
très bien renseigné effectivement il y a
un frein psychologique
30 % 30 % effectivement c'est l'ADEME
qui a montré ça que au-dessus de 30 %
généralement le consommateur se redirige
vers un achat de neuf ou un achat d'un
nouveau produit en tout cas c'est le cas
souvent bah alors justement si 80 78%
des Européens souhaiteraient réparer
leurs produits plutôt que d'en acheter
un neuf ça c'est une étude de Robert à
remettre mais seulement dans les fait
36% le font donc on voit qu'il y a un
fossé encore qui est assez énorme et
qu'on a encore du mal à combler et
ensuite c'est indice de réparabilité on
finit là-dessus va devenir ce sera l'an
prochain l'indice de durabilité
c'est-à-dire que désormais on va tester
aussi si un produit
pas seulement s'il est réparable mais
aussi s'il est robuste et là on se dit
parce que c'est mieux que notre appareil
ne tombe pas en panne c'est bien par le
réparer mais le mieux c'est qu'il dure
le plus longtemps possible et qui tombe
le plus tard possible en panne ouais
complètement un produit peut être
réparable mais pas durable et dans le
sens où votre produit vous pouvez le
réparer autant de fois que vous voulez
mais si derrière il y a il tombe en
panne tout le temps parce que il est pas
assez robuste parce que les pièces sont
pas été assez bien conçus ou parce que
il a engrangé du travail forcé ou parce
qu'il a un impact environnemental
extrêmement élevé il est pas durable
même s'il est réparable donc ça c'est
des critères supplémentaires que je
viens de citer qui doivent rentrer en
ligne de compte et il y a un deuxième
enjeu à l'indice de réparabilité c'est
l'élévation au niveau européen ça j'y
tiens vraiment beaucoup c'est que depuis
l'indice du réparabilité au niveau
français le niveau européen c'est en
étant pareil il y a une directive
maintenant pour faire un indice de
réparabilité européen et ça c'est
l'accès à 450 millions de consommateurs
de enfin c'est l'accès de ces 50 de ces
450 millions de consommateurs à un
indice de réparabilité qui concerne
potentiellement des milliards de
produits et l'Union européenne est le
premier marché du monde et c'est là que
fini la chaîne de valeur de la plupart
des entreprises et un indice de
réparabilité assez échelle on change
d'échelle on peut vraiment avoir un
énorme effet merci beaucoup donc Quentin
gecker de passer nous voir vous êtes le
président de l'association hop alt à
l'obsolescence programmée merci beaucoup
à vous et on vient de le voir les
consommateurs commencent peu à peu avoir
un peu plus le réflexe de réparer leur
appareil mais aura-t-on assez de
réparateur pour satisfaire toute la
demande comment être sûr de trouver les
bonnes pièces détachées reportage
signées manuels aujourd'hui 60% des
pannes d'appareils électriques et
électroniques ne sont pas réparés alors
pour y remédier depuis le 15 décembre
dernier l'État met la main à la poche
pour encourager les Français à prolonger
la durée de vie de leurs appareils et
réduire les déchets 10 à 15 euros d'aide
par réparation pour en bénéficier il
faut s'adresser aux 500 ateliers agréés
comme Murphy l'un des leaders du marché
on en voit pas beaucoup à céder comme ça
tu as de la valeur ça c'est demander en
région parisienne et tout des petits on
a du mal à en sortir mais ça fait
plaisir quand on a Murphy répare 5000
appareils d'électroménager chaque mois
et réalise un chiffre d'affaires de plus
de 5 millions d'euros si le coût de la
réparation avec cette pas 40 % du prix
du neuf en fait la plupart des
consommateurs préfèrent passer par la
réparation au niveau national on aura
réparé 100000 appareils en 2022 100 000
soit 0,4% des 28 millions d'appareils
ménagers qui tombent en panne chaque
année face à la demande qui explose la
main d'oeuvre est insuffisante non on a
formé on a embauché 150 réparateurs dans
les 18 derniers mois et là l'enjeu et
l'ambition c'est dans reformer dans
l'embaucher 300 dans les 18 prochains
mois donc on est sur une sur un enjeu
assez assez importante la France compte
5000 réparateurs sur tout le territoire
alors qu'il en faudrait le double pour
faire face à cette pénurie Murphy a pris
à bras le corps la situation en créant
sa propre école pour former les
réparateurs de ça peut être la carte
interface faut bien regarder donc on va
les retrouver ou sur le schéma
pendant 6 mois les élèves alternent
entre théorie et pratiques on voit de
tout du lave-linge à la cuisson en
passant par le réfrigérateur et on
détaille tout les principes de
fonctionnement des appareils avant j'ai
été restaurateur pendant 14 ans moi ce
qu'il me fallait c'est un métier qui
soit utile en fait la restauration c'est
bien mais c'est pas c'est pas vital en
fait c'est quand on n'a pas d'argent on
va pas au resto quoi mais quand ta
machine elle tombe en panne bah tu es
obligé de la faire réparer Sébastien
débutera sa carrière à 1800 euros brut
par mois et pourra doubler rapidement
ses revenus si le marché continue de
s'accroître mais pour relever le défi de
la réparabilité la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre n'est pas le seul obstacle
trouver les bonnes pièces détachées peut
aussi se révéler être un vrai casse-tête
nous sommes dans la banlieue de Lyon
chez Utopia spécialiste des pièces
détachées pour téléphone portable ici
30000 composants sont exp chaque jour
avec comme promesse une livraison
partout en France en 24 heures un
particulier casse son téléphone il
emmène à une boutique de réparation
cette boutique là n'a pas forcément la
pièce en stock elle va le commander sur
Utopia si on n'est pas capable nous de
livrer cette pièce détachées en 24
heures il y a des grandes chances que
vous n'alliez pas ça réparer votre
téléphone et que vous préfériez le
changer Aldric a créé Utopia en 2013 à
l'époque il livre lui-même à vélo les
réparateurs des environs depuis
l'entreprise connaît une forte
croissance plus 30% en moyenne chaque
année aujourd'hui son chiffre d'affaires
frôle les 60 millions d'euros ce qui est
intéressant c'est que là tu es sûr de
pouvoir faire des commandes quasiment
sans aucune erreur alors pour honorer
toujours plus de commandes en un temps
record Aldric a dû investir quelques
millions d'euros dans un entrepôt high
tech
numéro 20 là-bas n'est pas mal plus
besoin de marcher dans les allées pour
trouver la bonne référence 25 robots
très organisés se baladent parmi le
million de pièces détachées et la porte
directement au magasinier
le lancement
c'est facile à prendre en main quand
même finalement plus qu'on pensait non
selon Aldric la masse salariale n'aurait
pas vraiment diminué ce système lui
permettrait de limiter les erreurs de
commande de rendre la tâche plus
confortable pour le personnel
d'anticiper l'avenir et son nombre
croissant de commandes problème les
fabricants ne sont pas toujours très
collaboratifs et rechigne parfois à
fournir les bonnes pièces détachées
ont du mal à vous donner les pièces
détachées
c'est une bonne question on a toujours
eu des difficultés d'approvisionnement
nous en pièce détachés d'origine on
arrive à le faire de plus en plus avec
certaines marques mais de base c'est
vrai qu'on a toujours eu des difficultés
depuis 2013 à nous approvisionner en
pièces détachées d'origine constructeur
pourtant pour les smartphones
commerciaux depuis janvier 2022 les
constructeurs sont dans l'obligation de
mettre à disposition des réparateurs une
liste précise de pièces détachées
pendant 5 ans si certains constructeurs
ne jouent pas le jeu ce serait pour la
simple et bonne raison que réparer et
moins rentable que vendre du neuf mais
aussi parce que rendre disponible
certaines pièces dévoilerait les secrets
de fabrication
[Musique]
comment inciter les fabricants en faire
plus en matière de durabilité comme on
convaincre les consommateurs de réparer
plutôt que de racheter on en parle avec
vous Enrique Martinez bonjour bonjour
merci d'être avec nous d'être le
directeur général du groupe Fnac Darty
on l'a vu c'est indice de réparabilité
il était mis en place par le
gouvernement il est obligatoire depuis
2021 je me demandais est-ce que vous
l'affichez vraiment tout le temps dans
vos magasins sur votre site parce qu'on
était juste avant avec l'association alt
à l'obsolescence programmée qui nous
disait que tous les vendeurs tous les
distributeurs ne le faisaient pas vous
le fait tout le temps chez certains
quartiers alors les faits en fait il
sait très bien parce que même avant en
2018 grâce à eux il y avait comme des
Amis de la Terre on avait commencé à
s'intéresser au sujet de la réparabilité
il avait créé nos propres anti-céré par
altés sur le monde de l'ordinateur entre
autres on trouve que c'est un élément
indispensable aujourd'hui pour donner
une information juste au consommateur et
c'est devenu un des arguments principal
d'achat des produits et est-ce que tous
les fabricant parce que c'est ça dépend
de puisqu'il se note et ce qui joue le
jeu est-ce qu'il vous transmettent leur
note aujourd'hui les fabricants ils sont
très sensibles à des éléments qui sont
clés pour ces consommateurs et c'est un
élément qui a quelques années
probablement ça aurait été éviter parce
que c'était moins confortable et parler
des sacs et parler de l'innovation de la
technologie mais aujourd'hui ils ont
compris et particulièrement en France
parce qu'un sensibilité il y a la
législation qui est beaucoup plus
avancée que dans d'autres pays au monde
qui sont l'intérêt des alignés à la
France parce que ça va devenir en
tendance mondiale donc oui ils sont en
train de jouer les jeux qu'est-ce qui se
passe quand on fabriquant Enrique et
Martinez nous vous fournit pas la note
d'un produit est-ce que vous le retirez
de l'étal du rayon comme la loi le
prévoit aujourd'hui c'est une évidence
que on peut pas accepter des terribles
de la loi donc oui évidemment mais c'est
pas le cas et nous savons si ça devait
arriver si ça arrive on les faits mais
aujourd'hui nous on fait on joue avec
des acteurs mondiaux responsables et on
fait des sélection la sélection ça sert
à ça aussi pas seulement choisir le bon
produit mais les bons comportements de
nos partenaires et ils vont jouer j'ai
totalement confiance à eux bon vous
l'avez dit à demi-mot chef indice vous
ne l'avez pas attendu vous l'avez
précédé vous l'avez même un petit peu
inspiré donc avec le labo Fnac c'est ça
tout à fait
intéresser à la performance des produits
on est là 2018 c'est ça 2018 et on a
commencé je me souviens qu'on avait fait
une visite avec quelques journalistes
pour les montrer les tripes d'un
ordinateur en fait nos équipes du labo
nos techniciens nous expliquer la
différence de temps et des et des
faisabilité d'échanger un batterie qui
était insérés dans 4 Liars et qui
s'apprenait une heure et demie à les
sortir ou un ordinateur qui était
impossible et d'ouvrir et donc il est
pas réparable et que ça c'était plus
acceptable alors on va voir comment vous
cherchez chez funk Darty à accompagner
les consommateurs qui veulent être plus
responsables vous avez plusieurs outils
on va les passer un petit peu en revue
il y a le baromètre SAV qu'on retrouve
sur sur Internet c'est une espèce quoi
de palmarès des des produits qui sont
les plus fiables et les plus réparables
en fait on a trouvé qu'il y a une mine
d'or depuis des années parce que vous
savez on répare plus de 2 millions des
produits par an et donc on a
l'information prédictive de tout ce qui
peut arriver en produits
avec nos fabricants mais qu'on n'avait
jamais partagé avec les consommateurs et
on a dit au contraire donner on va la
partager il faut la partager il faut on
est dans le monde de la donnée du Data
c'est data c'est une data qui est
perruche et hyper propre donc on va
donner la chance à tous les marques des
jouets positifs pour améliorer son
escort et ça nous permet à nous d'avoir
un émulation positive et aux marques des
faire des efforts qui payent et en quoi
ce baromètre il se différencie de
l'indice de réparabilité du gouvernement
est-ce que votre baromètre va peut-être
plus loin que l'indice il est un peu
plus loin parce que la fiabilité la
robustesse du produit voilà nous on va
chercher tous nos statistiques sur
comptabilité des produits après on va
intégrer en dimension des disponibilités
pour réparer un produit d'abord il faut
qu'il tombe en panne très souvent
les pieds il faut qu'il soit disponible
vraiment et dans la durée et après on va
s'intéresser aussi aux choses des prix
des pièces parce qu'en fait tout ça doit
être son ensemble il faut que la
réparation soit possible et
économiquement viable et pour tout le
monde ok il y a un deuxième outil il
faut qu'on en parle aussi qui est à
disposition des consommateurs c'est
l'étiquette choix durable on a trouvé en
magasin et l'idée c'est de mettre en
valeur un champion dans sa catégorie
c'est intéressant et c'est intéressant
parce que ça ramène aux produits et en
fait si on prend une catégorie quand les
grosses électroménagers qui nous vient
rapidement à l'esprit on en parle des
réparations aujourd'hui c'est les
premiers critères de choix d'un
consommateur face à un rayon des
produits en électroménager un
électroménager d'autres catégories pété
de savoir arriver en deux ou un 3 parce
que c'est design etc mais je voulais
électroménager la question c'est pour
combien de temps ça va durer chez moi et
donc on a dit c'est l'information qui
est relevante pour le consommateurs de
son choix il faut créer ces étiquettes
des choix durables donc si je suis
consommateur et que chez Darty j'ai deux
affichages et l'indice de réparabilité
du gouvernement et j'ai l'étiquette
choix durable c'est pas un peu confusant
c'est pas compliqué pour le client de
s'y retrouver c'est le vendeur qui va
faire les critères juste c'est
l'information qui est Darty enfin Darty
à il a fourni avant le marché où on n'a
pas attendu avoir ce baromètre tant
mieux que ça arrive ça va permettre de
mettre tout le monde sur les mêmes
créneaux mais j'ai confiance mes
vendeurs sont capables de donner du sens
à tous ces informations qui sont pas
contradictoires ça peut être même
complémentaire et ce baromètre
cette étiquette donc c'est destiné en la
compris aux consommateurs après on
revient fabricant et je reviens à ma
question est-ce que vous avez
l'impression qu'ils font des efforts non
pas sur leur note mais est-ce qu'il
propose des produits qui sont ben voilà
plus plus réparables plus robustes il y
a une tendance vraiment tout à fait et
en fait ils ont pas des choix parce que
dès lors qu'ils sont mal placés dans ces
escorts des différentes démarques il
commence à avoir un problème des accès
au marché parce que nous en tant
déjà les consommateurs
mais je pense que celles qui traînent
les pieds ils vont comprendre et ça paye
pas trop ils vont être obligés on le
voit dans les design des produits il y a
une forte amélioration ces dernières
temps pour rendre les produits plus
réparables et plus accessibles en fait
dans les design du produit quel est le
sujet de la réparation qui est beaucoup
mieux pris en compte qui avant et puis
elle est soja de rentrer le poulet plus
fiable et là nous on contribue avec tous
nos données statistiques pour un
feedback régulière pour les advertir que
certains design particulières ils ont eu
peu provoquer des dysfonctionnements
chez les clients parfois c'est pas
disponible technique en soi c'est
mauvais utilisation des produits du
client fait particulièrement peut avoir
un impact et ils sont l'intérêt de
corriger en tout cas ce qui nous
concerne à nous les produits qui sont
les moins virtuels on arrive à les
sortir de nos catalogue voilà je pense
qu'il y a la motivation intéressante
pour les faire vous assumez de sortir
des catalogues si le produit n'est pas
assez dur ce n'est pas assez réparable
ou bien des sortir un abonnement
illimité des réparations qui s'appelle
Darty max donc en fait on est intéressé
avec les produits tombent pas parce que
on est responsable pour les réparer donc
c'est pas comme avant que vous dire en
fait vous êtes intéressé que les
produits tombent en panne parce que vous
allez faire du bénéfice aujourd'hui j'ai
fait des je fais pas des bénéfices si
vous prenez dans ma banque c'est moi qui
va les réparer gratuitement vous avez
lancé vous en avez parlé de ce service
d'abonnement réparation limitée avec une
prise en charge à 100% de la réparation
de tous les produits qui sont des
produits vendus par par la maison est-ce
que vous voyez Enrique Martinez un
engouement de la part des des clients
pour ça parce que j'ai vu pour 2023
votre objectif c'était 2 millions
d'adhérents pour 2023 on y sera ou pas
bah on n'est pas loin on est dans la
trajectoire
donc
on n'est pas encore dans les moments de
bilan de bilan annuel ça va arriver il y
a quelques dans quelques semaines mais
je pense que bientôt j'espère pouvoir
inviter mes partenaires pour fêter les
premiers millions et après il viendra la
deuxième et après on va continuer
aujourd'hui une deuxième vision sera en
2023 ou plus tard on verra bien mais
déjà on va faire nos engagements des
deux mais en fait qu'on en a sorti les
programmes il paraissait impossible
parce que les choses de la réparation
c'est pas au quotidien des clients
aujourd'hui et en plus avec la crise
c'est l'inflexion ça devient encore plus
pertinent parce que tout le monde a
envie de faire des économies aussi donc
si j'ai bien compris on finit là-dessus
vous êtes en train de de faire évoluer
votre modèle votre business model comme
on dit en anglais chef un Darty est-ce
que vous prenez pas un risque parce que
qui dit plus de réparation dit moins de
vente
donc faut que l'abonnement d'artimax
qu'on pense peut-être une baisse des
ventes si les gens rachètent moins
puisqu'il réparent ils regardent plus
longtemps ses vertueux d'un point de vue
écologique mais que il y a une prise de
risque chez Fnac Darty la vie c'est un
risque mais je pense qu'il faut être
dans l'heure du temps la modernité
aujourd'hui les clients comme Darty je
pense qu'il a toujours fait la Fnac
aussi c'est accompagnée pour des
produits plus de qualité il y a un
service qui accompagne les clients dans
la durée ces dernières années on a vu
arriver dans notre métier beaucoup des
mondes qui a porté par la brique service
mais que les consommateurs ils sont
acceptés à avoir une vente sans service
je pense que demain ça sera plus les cas
donc même si globalement les marchés ne
pourra faire moins d'évoles je pense que
des secteurs engagés qui proposent du
service probablement ils seront pas des
gâteaux un peu important en tout cas
c'est mon objectif c'est pas forcément
que j'ai eu à vendre moins c'est que les
marchés faire un problème moins d'éolum
inutiles des volumes plus des qualités
soutenables et que nous et pour un autre
collègue qui vont prendre les mêmes
schémas que nous en bas faire une partie
du marché un peu plus importante merci
pour cet entretien de Rick et Martinez
le directeur général du groupe Fnac
Darty voilà c'est la fin de pourvu que
ça dure l'émission qui rend les
correspondables émissions à voir ou
revoir évidemment sur Public Sénat le
replay c'est toujours sur public Senna
rendez-vous dans deux semaines
[Musique]
c'était pourvu que ça dure avec le
soutien déco des déesses
[Musique]